Why do I not hear anything from my right machine at different times and then at other times I hear a beeping sound?
Well, that's because the right machine makes different noises and the bulb pulses at different frequencies
and the bulb lights at different intensities depending upon what frequency is being used in the program.
So with the true right, it's running one frequency at any given time and if you're running very high frequencies with the true right,
you're going to see less light coming out of the machine and you're going to see here less noise.
Now typically with the true right, you'll always hear the noise with the Atelier Robin if you're running a harmonic with the machine.
So if I wrote the program and there's different times in your program that you're running a harmonic,
so you're running multiple frequencies at once, then it's going to be much quieter.
And if it's a high harmonic, so if the original frequency is 2000 hertz, let's say, and then at the 11th harmonic of that is 22,000 hertz,
you're running those two frequencies at the same time, you typically won't hear anything.
So it literally muffles the sound, you'll hear very little, you have to switch your ear up to it to really hear the machine.
So at different times, it's not going to make any sound.
And it's going to be much fader light since you're running two frequencies at the same time.
So you may not even, during the day, you might not be able to see anything coming out of the bulb.
That's the same thing with the true right, during the day. It's difficult to see anything coming out of the bulb.
Now typically at lower frequencies, you'll see that more intense.
And you'll hear it more intense with both the true right for the until they're up.
And so it has to do with the frequencies that are currently running based upon the program that you're running.
We had somebody send a bulb back in the day saying that there was something wrong with the bulb.
We couldn't hear any noise coming from the sheet, could not hear anything coming from the,
couldn't see any light coming from the bulb.
And I believe this person was mistaken. There's nothing wrong with the bulb. They're mistaken.
So sometimes people go, I woke up at one o'clock and I couldn't, you know, hear anything.
Not by a right wasn't working. Well, it's just at that given time.
The program that was running the frequency of running that different time at that given time were probably in a harmonic mode and a high frequency.
And that's why you couldn't hear anything.
And they may say, well, I woke up at one last night and I could hear it going.
I had to go to the bathroom. I tend to get up at one o'clock. Well, it was a different program last night.
So just understand that. Of course, you're if you're at pitch black darkness and you're running the machine and there's no light coming out of the bulb.
And you're definitely in pitch black darkness. Then there's something wrong.
So all sorts of possible things you could have accidentally bumped the machine where the front of the machine,
where you're instead of running on bulb or tube or the plasma, you're running on the foot bath or something like that.
So of course you can see anything coming out of the bulb if you haven't run it on the foot bath.
And a pretty good chance you could possibly damage your bulb if you were doing that.
Make sure you are treating your machine with good gloves and you understand you have a expensive, very delicate piece of equipment that you have to be careful with.
Sometimes it's easy to forget that when we get used to something and we're running it all the time and we're used to something we forget to care for like it's a delicate piece of equipment.
And then any bait around or bumping into things you can break the thing. It's like anything else.
So just be careful with that and understand that.